ugh would you calm down now read my lips
we gotta talk one of the hardest jobs in
visual effects is making animals look
realistic when they talk it's a
challenge effect studio weta digital has
taken on and if you look at weta's
talking fox from the 2021 movie the
green knight you can see just how far
we've come but getting from here oh my i
can't ask him that to hear to end his
song is he so fit wasn't easy
when the whole cg talking animal genre
was born in the 90s filmmakers faced one
overarching challenge how do you make a
fundamentally unbelievable thing
believable before movies would just dub
over the mouth movements of live animal
actors or animatronic puppets and later
moved to compositing footage of live
animals with 3d digital models of the
animal's mouths over the years studios
like wetta have mastered the art of
creating fully digital creatures that
speak and express themselves in
naturalistic ways
mike was one of the lead animators on
rise of the planet of the apes where the
chimpanzee caesar slowly learns to
converse with humans
human actors not only voiced but
actually played the apes filming in
motion capture suits that tracked their
movements
weta's animators then had to map those
performances onto the digital eight
models making the apes deliver their
lines and emote in ways that stayed true
to the actors choices without feeling
too human
the very different anatomies of humans
and apes often made it impossible to
exactly translate those acting choices
one for one in dialogue scenes for
example apes have heavier brows and
larger neck muscles which had to move
differently when the apes were speaking
making sure that we've got the wrinkling
working well how the muzzle inflates how
still he is when he says his line
sometimes that isn't a dead translation
nowhere are the anatomical differences
more extreme than in that mouth area
which is obviously crucial for dialogue
the muzzle on a chimpanzee for example
is a lot more malleable and dextrous
than a human mouth the apes have the
ability to move their lips in such
big ways compared to humans that meant
that in some cases animators had to
blend some of the actors human lip
shapes onto the digital facial puppets
of the apes like when pronouncing the
phoneme
a chimp's lips extend into a long pucker
to make this shape which would distract
from the actual dialogue so we'd arrange
that in tightening the mouth shape and
keeping a fuller more human lip these
lip and snout differences between humans
and apes actually made andy circus a
perfect casting choice for caesar since
he often articulates with his lips while
delivering lines andy can be an over
performer he started in early days of
motion capture when the fidelity wasn't
as good it didn't capture as much motion
so when you see him
perform for caesar he does move his lips
a little bit more than you you typically
expect when you actually talk to him in
person beyond the most visible parts of
the mouth
spends a lot of time looking at dental
scans of actors teeth and video showing
how the tongue moves inside the mouth
all that internal structure inevitably
drives how the surface of a mouth
behaves how the body behaves apes and
any other character animal we're doing
we can actually take the geometry of
their mouth their teeth their gums their
tongue
so that the same way we know how lips
move over a human's skeleton the same
thing is going to happen with a with a
dog with an aid that close understanding
of mouth anatomy came into play on the
jungle book where whether had to make
the giant orangutan king louie not only
talk but sing animators had to figure
out just how far to hold louie's tongue
back in his mouth when he sang his lines
you'll see it's true
someone like me
[Music]
in the end though animation supervisor
paul story said his team had to sell the
singing performance with body motion
first like by carefully timing louie's
chest movements to show him breathing in
between lines of song and by
coordinating his body movements with
every little head motion a lot of which
was based on videos of christopher
walken reading his lines
when wheda made dogs talk and sing for
another live-action remake lady and the
[ __ ] animators kept an even lighter
touch on the mouth area the difference
between ape's mouth and a dog's mouth is
you know like a dog's got a long muzzle
and as soon as you start doing too much
with the jaw
it suddenly becomes this over animated
performance and if you've got really
fast dialogue or somebody's singing a
song it quickly falls apart the thing
that we found with dogs and and the fox
in particular was if we push the
performance out to the front of the
mouth and then supported that
performance in the rest of the face and
all the way down into the body i think
that really kind of grounds it well this
is goodbye i think yep
bye bye this approach to the fox and the
green knight helped guard the mystery
around him since he talks in what feels
like a dream state director david lowry
wanted to keep viewers guessing
the dialogue
was almost like wait
did i just see that is that talking
david wanted to keep it so subtle and
such a character that you never really
understood
so the animators focused on making the
fox's breath move through his body as he
speaks and on nailing the subtle
movements in the nose neck and jowls
they even zoomed into parts of the body
you wouldn't think of as being tied to
speech like timing the fox's vocal
delivery with his footsteps and the
twitching of his ears
they're all folding into that little bit
of dialogue so the dialogues may be
subtle on the front of the muzzle but
the whole
character is speaking including maybe
most importantly through the eyes we've
always known that the eyes are where you
get a lot of the performance out of the
characters that's why wet is always
improving the way it models its eyes
including parts that we don't even see
on camera if you go back to gollum the
eyes we had it was three pieces of
geometry with painted textures on them
our eyes have so much depth in them now
that you can actually fly right into
them we actually put all the proper
strings and muscles in connecting the
people and generating the iris and
everything we've talked to eye doctors
we've got eye scans what is animators
have found that for dialogue scenes
nailing eye focus is key
and so we're really specific about
making sure that there's something even
in the digital space off-camera that
isn't even going to be in the shot that
the characters are focusing on the
studios also learned that our eyes are
constantly making tiny movements to take
in new pieces of a scene even when we
appear to be holding a steady gaze
there's this extra little bit of motion
that sits on top of all that detailed
performance for emotional dialogue
moments like this one the team consulted
with an eye surgeon to learn how
moisture beats up on the eyeballs and
runs into the fold between the lower lid
and the eyeball the blood flow as
someone's crying you get that actual
reddening in the cluncula and you really
feel that emotion come through with all
that extra detail that obsessive level
of detail has made it possible to branch
out into new types of talking animals
even the swimming kind in season two of
the umbrella academy after creating the
chimp pogo for the netflix series huetto
was recruited to build a talking
goldfish your recovery has been an
inspiration to us all this character aj
carmichael was a new sort of challenge
according to animation supervisor aiden
martin since normal fish don't even have
tongues and there aren't many parts of a
fish's face that would articulate the
way we see with human speech but whereas
animators found a solution adding
controls to aj's lips and mouth so they
could overlap allowing a wider range of
mouth shapes as he delivers his lines
it's all about hitting that sweet spot
between what's anatomically possible and
what looks credible on screen what has
mastered that balance to create talking
animal characters that are every bit as
expressive and believable as their human
counterparts do not
come back
[Music]
you